Alright, this one is mostly for my Charleston people.
So I was leaving the opening party
for Charleston Wine and Food Festival last night.
It is by far my favorite time of year.
We have some of the best chefs
and best food in the country
in my opinion.
So food and Wine Fest is just the best.
But I had an amazing lift driver
who was driving me home.
He was a born and raised Charlestonian
and we were talking about
how much the city has changed and grown
and who can call themselves a local.
Cause in my opinion,
when I moved here 13 years ago,
I was told that the only way that you could tell
anybody that you were Charleston locals
if you were born and raised here,
and preferably
if your family was also born and raised here.
Now don't get me wrong,
I would love to be able to rock things and say like
Charleston local on them,
but I am very aware of the fact
that I am still a New Yorker.
I don't think that'll ever change.
He was of the opinion that
if you've lived here for 10 years plus,
you can call yourself a local now.
So I wanna hear your opinions
from people who live in Charleston,
both born and raised and transplants.
Do you call yourself a local?
Were you born and raised here?
And who can call themselves a local?
And is all this just silly gatekeeping?
I don't know.
But you won't catch me in some local shit
until I get the approval.